on a panel that's a round table and the
topic will be reporting on Ukraine and
as you know from the program which you
have as well as I do we have with us for
practitioners this will not be an
academic panel per se although you
shouldn't leave the room as a result
okay this will be a panel devoted to the
actual practice of reporting on Ukraine
by people reporting on Ukraine in
Ukraine Mumbai people reporting on
Ukraine outside Ukraine to my left is
Andrew your kofsky I mean you can read
the biographies he comes to us from
deutsche messe augen tour where he had
been based with them in vienna and had
the opportunity for several years to
cover much of eastern europe as well as
Ukraine then to his left is Elana Tahu
currently with the global education
leadership and NGO and before that she
had spent a number of years working for
the Union news agency then the basava
gun Gaza who works for voice of america
and finally Brian Bonner of the editor
of Kiev post if you've been to Kiev you
seen the kyiv post and I'm sure you've
read it religiously so we have a variety
of perspectives we have people from
print journalism we have people in radio
we have people who have an
administrative position but also write
we also have people who actually do the
actual writing and last but not least we
have individuals from within and from
without Ukraine the way this is going to
work is I will well it's a round table
I'll ask questions they'll provide
answers and we'll go round in a kind of
round robin along with interventions of
various kinds so by all means feel free
to do so this will go on for our guests
about an hour and a half roughly and
then we'll leave you the esteemed
audience with a near 15 minutes for Q&A
presumably by then we will all be tired
and or scintillating presumably a
combination of both and that will end
the conference so let me start with the
fundamental in a way is kind of easy
the question that is on every journalist
mind regardless of where he or she is
station and regardless of what they may
be writing about in which medium they're
writing for namely how do you interest a
reader in this particular beat in the
story in the region how do you interest
readers in Ukraine what's the hook
what's the story is there a story Andrew
well I've always taken Ukraine to be
interesting in and of itself that's
certainly not enough to get down what
I'm sorry that's certainly not enough to
get coverage one of the things that I
think one needs in order to get
attention to it is to put what's going
on Ukraine into a global perspective why
does it matter for the rest of Europe so
for example the gas story the cutting
off of gas supplies the development of
new pipelines those are obviously very
big stories human rights democratization
the rest of Timoshenko those things sort
of write themselves I think it's more
difficult though to to do reporting that
shows what's actually going on in
Ukraine why ukraine is interesting in
and of itself and it strikes me that a
lot of the coverages i've been
responsible for and a lot of the
coverage that you see let's say in
journal general interest publications
like the New York Times focus on cry
season and the the extent to which
Ukraine is becoming a normal country how
it is transfer is transitioning to
something that you would call normal and
I think it would for my taste would be
interesting to try to find out what is
what is common in Ukraine with other
places what is interesting what Ukraine
produces that sub value and I don't know
that we as journalists in the West are
terribly good at that but I think that
is really a next step that we should be
moving toward because I see having
covered or edited reporters who cover
all of Eastern Europe the continued
marginalization of this part of the
world except as it pertains to
economics because all the major wire
services and and newspapers are in
somewhere either covering the markets in
that region so what I would like to see
myself is something is a focus on these
countries as Ukraine and other Eastern
European countries it's something of
value in and of themselves not as select
kind of a scientific cases it is it
achieving something already well what
exactly is a Valerie Messick that's a
question that I know how do you exactly
conveyed I mean you know aside from the
beautiful steps and the mountains and
all those sorts of things I mean hello I
think one of the things you can do this
is how you make a story interesting is
it strikes me for a place like Ukraine
or places that were nothing you know
serious is happening is to find some
kind of a cultural peg that makes it
interesting that you find something that
resonates with in American culture that
that you can make it familiar with or
you can make a contrast with and that's
really what you do I think in order to
make something makes sense that's what a
lot of the feature reporting that you
see in the New York Times about foreign
countries does if it is in something
really breaking its how does it how is
this like or not like the United States
there they're obviously risks that but i
but i also think that when i have this
question because when I'm when i myself
am following events in Ukraine I'm
really following political events and
after following political events in the
daily minutiae of government you ask
yourself either is there something more
and it strikes me that when we're used
to looking at Eastern Europe as a block
we did see something more than just the
politics much more than we do now and
that's culture and that doesn't really
come through I don't know the people who
are actually living in Ukraine and
experiencing Ukrainian culture directly
they might have something to say about
that but I find it really sort of
disturbing when you think about it that
the Balkans is the Balkans our former
Yugoslavia is consider kind of a problem
but then you look at the kind of
literature and artistic creation that
came out of there 20 years ago and it
doesn't compare to you know in my mind
anything that's being produced in the
United States right now so what does
zero value
that would be something interesting to
to show what would not that these are
countries are from over there and and
are different from the West but how do
they interact with the west and we're
used to referring to Ukraine as being a
part of well depending on which which
territory were talking about Eastern
Europe or a central europe and i read
recently on a listserv for historians
called Habsburg somebody suggesting that
we call it wider Europe I think that
would be kind of an interesting way of
looking at it because it is it is
different it does have different
historical experiences but there's a
commonality that can be brought out and
and made interesting I think to a
Western audience and that's not being
done well then you've been in the United
States for the last few years you've
been reporting on Ukraine and of course
been dealing with an American audience
what is there a valley what are the
commonalities between Ukraine and
Americans alright well I'll give you
three real life examples to explain how
the situation is well first of all
yesterday for example I was interviewing
Fareed Zakaria and I was trying to make
him say something about Ukraine he
doesn't know much about Ukraine of
course and he just told me explicitly
you know Ukraine is off the map and I
just it's hard for me to get my viewers
on CNN interested even in Europe and we
not even me no speak about Ukraine
second example is when I was reporting
for New York Times a little bit when i
was in kiev last year and they did not
have any correspondent in kiev at that
time and they only have Moscow Bureau
and Moscow Bureau they are very people
who know Russia well and they think
Russia is important and it is a
geopolitical player and for them some
small event in some distant region of
Russia would seem more important than
major national event in Ukrainian
capital and it was very hard
to get them interested in any Ukrainian
story unless it is something big like
Yulia Tymoshenko going to prison and
third example is when I tried you know I
mom I was collaborating a little bit
with foreign policy magazine in
Washington DC and they said that they
did research on different countries if
you if you write a story about a country
and as you know foreign policy rights
and lyrical pieces analyzing kino rise
of China liberalization in Burma so
those countries they would attract
readership but they say if they have the
same article about Ukraine they know
that there will be very few clicks that
Ukraine is in the list of least
interesting countries for them this is
why it's so hard to publish anything on
Ukraine this is why my answer would be
that it is easier to get breasts in
media American media interested not in
Ukraine per se as a country but in our
personalities like for example femina
from Ukraine but it doesn't prevent them
to be popular everywhere they had their
show on PBS here in the United States
they were covered than everywhere in
Europe or some other personalities like
Timoshenko some smart kids who have high
you know I cues and achievements in
computer science some programmers that
sold their products to Google something
like that it would sell much better
because unfortunately as the country
ukraine is not doing well in Western
media right now okay so notice lava I
mean pursuing that point I mean on why
exactly is Ukraine done interesting i
think most people in this room would
agree that it's intrinsically
interesting for all sorts of reasons is
it simply because it's a foreign country
and americans don't care is it because
it's in the shadow of Russia and Russia
dominates the news or is it because it's
just fundamentally crummy no I think I
think
Ilana make a very good point that
Ukraine is not a geopolitical player and
that's the answer to to why you're not
why we are not interested until Ukraine
would not put their finger in the map
and would stand up and have a position
as long we would not be interesting
Ukraine is not sexy there is nothing
happening there we are not a threat to
anyone we're just in in Billund country
in the middle of Europe and until we
would not have I mean we have to have
Stan we have to have position we have to
have a foreign policy that would that we
can be I mean we can stand for some
position the other otherwise it would
never be interesting I don't think you
you would be able to to interest people
otherwise i can share life experience as
well from my work at Voice of America
when we are at the editorial meetings in
central news division nobody talks about
Ukraine something happened in Russia
little thing would happen in Russia
everyone would talk about it would think
how to cover the story Ukraine even the
big things doesn't really interest
anyone if something big happened in
Ukraine nobody is interesting so it's
very very difficult to push Ukrainians
story for the for the world coverage so
but there was any during the orange
revolution Ukraine was in the news yes
because because there was a lot of big
protest there was a threat so far maybe
a civil war there was a lot of question
what would happen to the country and
what happened to the bordering countries
that's why it was interesting maybe next
to orange revolution or whatever blue
revolution would would bring interest to
Ukraine Brian your take on these points
well two things I'm not Ukrainian but
deeply deeply interested in fascinated
by the Ukrainian story and I think it's
one of the great stories of of all time
and that's why I continue to to try to
tell it and that's why we do it at the
kief post but I also agree that I mean
we're it's because exceedingly difficult
and we're a small market as powerful and
as influential and as great as we think
the kief post is we still have a
circulation of 20,000 papers on Friday
and Kiev that's all and on a good day we
have ten thousand readers on our website
now if there are five million Ukrainians
living abroad and there's only ten
thousand people reading the kief post
then they're getting their news from
somewhere else it's discouraging it
doesn't keep me from living in Ukraine
I've had the chance to live in
Washington DC Moscow I'd rather be where
I am in Kiev let's just pursue when we
wrangle to this I mean and remand your
original point was that the way to make
Ukraine interesting is to focus on
culture cultural compatibilities and the
rest I mean a number of your colleagues
essentially suggested that it's really
the geopolitics that matters and as long
as that Ukraine is irrelevant to the
world you can talk presumably you can
talk about as much culture as you like
and turn blue in the face but it won't
make much of a difference or do you see
culture as the ledge that can actually
break this this this this wall of
indifference of fellow there's another
issue that we can go into this as well
as the problem of foreign foreign
coverage in general on the one hand if
you really are interested in the country
you can get as much information as you
want now that everything is out there if
you speak languages you can you can get
almost anything but in traditional media
and in television even in let's say
stations like CNN and BBC that pretend
to cover the world and really don't you
don't there's no room for it and in fact
if you try to picture stories of
freelancer why don't you try GlobalPost
because we have no room on the LA Times
we don't have any room for foreign
coverage sample papers that used to be
gray papers oh we're getting everything
from the wire service so in terms of
a page in on Ukraine or you know
probably any country unless it's
something to do with the European
country unless it's something to do with
the euro crisis it's just very very hard
so you have to get it I think you
alluded two personalities that's
important also technology after our
technological developments business
stories I would say that the Financial
Times has an incredible amount of
coverage on on Ukraine and in fact they
probably publish a story almost every
other day if it's not in a blog if it's
an economic story of some kind so that
kind of coverage does get in the
business the business media is covering
Ukraine quite well but if you're going
to try to get into a general interest
media trying to attract readers who
don't have an interest in economics you
don't have an interest in geopolitics
and you know obviously Ukraine is kind
of on the margin of geopolitics you have
to introduce some interest them in
something that is maybe intrinsically
interesting like a personality somebody
who has done something because we're all
are interested in reading about
personalities or development some kind
of a commercial development some sort of
niche that Ukraine is getting in and two
and so in order to write about Ukraine
you have to not only make it interesting
to the audience but first of all you've
got a pitch it to a very cynical editor
who says look I've got no no room for
foreigners so how do you how do you do
that so you have two very difficult
selling points so his personality of the
way to go well yeah absolutely you need
to find something unusual something
attention-grabbing you know I
participated last year in the World
Economic Forum as like representative of
Ukraine and we had the meeting with Bill
Gates and before meeting with Bill Gates
his assistant she was kind of preparing
us how to start a conversation with Bill
Gates and he she says you know bill is
not interested in what you do who you
are he's interested in facts and some
interesting information so when you see
him don't say I'm Elena I do this and
that just say hey I'm Elena from Ukraine
do you know by the way that one-third of
our parliament has criminal record
and bill would be fascinated and this
this woman his assistant she is American
she lives in Seattle how does she know
that you see so basically but I wouldn't
like to present Ukraine that way you see
that's the point so you need to be
either sensational and negative and find
some bad stuff or try to find some good
stuff unfortunately at this moment
Ukraine has more bad stuff than good
stuff to show to the audience so that's
that's a dilemma for us if we care about
the external image of Ukraine how do we
get people interested without letting
people know that one-third of our
parliament has criminal record there was
a lot of coverage about Ukraine pre
coverage before event and I mean
majority of the coverage was very
negative toward Ukraine toward Ukrainian
population of dangerous all that stuff
and my daughter was reading all this
stories and she was very upset about why
they talked about Ukraine so badly and
she actually wrote a piece that would
pop was published in in Kyiv post and
she was trying to explain that it's not
as bad yes there is a lot of bad things
but you have to be try to be objective
about about coverage but that's that
that's not a sister story about that
well of course part of the problem is I
mean once the country seems to have
fallen into this kind of zone of crumb
eNOS it's very difficult to get out of
it without some sort of major
breakthrough me because the the working
assumption is that it's lousy and
anything you say that might be positive
or send my positive sound begins to
sound like an apologia for the
free which of course immediately turns
off readers because they think you've
got an agenda of some kind